[Applaudissements]
une réforme qui divise autant qu'elle
une ce sont près de dix huit professions
libérales qui se sont réunis dans les
rues de paris
objectif dénoncer l'augmentation de
leurs cotisations
d'après ces professionnels la réforme
des retraites pourrait déclencher la
disparition d'un grand nombre
d'entreprises
une mobilisation entamée depuis près de
quatre semaines par les professionnels
de justice attendue du louvre de
cotisation va faire enquête 1 22%
un certain nombre de cabinets vont
devoir mourir et les personnels sont
menacés c'est quand même un grand
paradoxe aujourd'hui dans le discours
c'est que on a une caisse qui fonctionne
parfaitement et on veut la supprimer
pour entrer dans un régime que l'on sait
qu'il ne va pas fonctionner une
manifestation qui fait suite à l'appel
du collectif sos retraite dont les
revendications ne sont pas les mêmes que
celles de la mobilisation
interprofessionnelle dont les syndicats
ont appelé à un nouveau rassemblement ce
jeudi
en attendant les avocats sont reçus ce
mardi par le premier ministre edouard
philippe
pour tenter de trouver un compromis sur
le projet de réforme
[Musique]